[Music]
hello there fortnite storyline is a
complex blend of brilliance and wtf
moments and now we are four years deep
into an ever evolving narrative and
predicting the future of the island is
almost impossible but that doesn't stop
us each day we receive a little more law
revealing items and characters from the
past suddenly becoming more important
remember when fade arrived and we all
thought his back bling was disgusting
then a year later it became the infinite
bloom a pivotal part of the storyline
and the collapse of reality today we
break down six fortnight theories that
are so dumb they could be true oh and do
me a favor use code adamaru if this
video helped waste some of your time
today let's do this
[Music]
our first theory is something that could
happen this week thanks to what's going
on at the convergence right now do you
remember last season at the end of the
season many leakers told us that we
could expect an egyptian poi and a
pyramid coming to fortnite and then
season eight began and no there's
nothing in sight there's hardly any sand
too well you may want to keep an eye on
cubetown this week there's going to be
18 updates to this place and it's
possible that it's making a freaking
pyramid right now very close by there is
an egyptian npc who talks about
traveling across the sand and i don't
see any sound around here unless the
queen has other plans and we all know
how pyramids are made blocks lots of
blocks it won't look like this i just
thought it would be fun to see i'm just
waiting for midas to touch it now and
turn it to gold some leakers have said a
line of code referencing the queen being
on top of a pyramid are in the files so
is this too good to be true is the queen
reshaping reality with those cubes or
will this just be a huge kevin the cube
in the middle of the map the potential
here is limitless the queen could burst
from her bubble bringing back the sand
biome just like the ice king did with
snow
[Applause]
[Music]
theory two is a brand spanking new one
that arrived on the island this week
dark jonesy has the halloween quest line
right now most of us grab the challenges
and get them done without listening to
what the character says so i'll break it
down as we all know each jonesy is a
snapshot and they were once a real
person bunker jonesy was the first to
leap into the zero point scuba johnsy
was sent to research what was under the
waves of the island and agent jonesy
jumped in to save reality each jon jones
has a purpose which leads us to dark
jonesy according to his blurb he has
seen beyond the darkness
dark jonesy tells us that io possess
powerful artifacts that can communicate
with the spirit world by trapping them
in a spirit vessel and look how that's
being done scrolls look familiar to you
the last one we saw was used by raz at
the spire he found that offerings of
life could ramp up its energy which in
turn attracted the last reality dark
johnsy on the other hand uses an urn the
place we put ashes of the fallen
completing his tasks will give us this
chilling reveal my vision is now clear
but i bring dark tidings two paths lay
ahead of you one path i see sacrifice
and loss on the other total annihilation
the last time a jonesy snapshot told us
something like this we were attacked by
a huge alien mothership so it's safe to
say someone in the storyline will be
making a huge sacrifice at the end of
this season's story but who could it be
any ideas name them in the comments and
let's see who the real oracle of the
community is my money is on sloan but
now i'm thinking it might be dark jonesy
taking a sacrifice to save the island
and our reality
speaking of that mysterious place jonesy
comes from beyond the darkness our third
theory is that we've been there before
[Music]
scoot back a few years to a much simpler
time in fortnite and the last time we
saw the cubes what if going beyond the
darkness is here in the pure light the
place we met the butterfly for the first
time this would work nicely as an astral
plane between realities and to the
untrained eye this place could literally
be nothing an empty space
this could also tie into the queen's
plans leave nothing behind she says
nothing behind
but she doesn't feel the same about
butterflies as us
if this space is between worlds we
should also note that singularity has
been here her helm sat here by the zero
point the first time we saw it before
she built a mech and flew into space
which is actually not the worst way a
girlfriend has left me hey i know this
isn't much to go on but adding a little
bit of law to that random space we went
to would really help what is this
nothingness
[Music]
theory 4 is all about the man with all
the answers midas but not the midas
you're thinking of this one midas rex
since season 2 of the chapter midas has
been one of the most loved skins whether
you choose shadow or ghost or prefer
looking gold his law is evolving fast
with the addition of his daughter the
engineer plus there are three versions
of him or at least three other people
with golden powers oro aurelia and
marigold yet midas law is still hidden
and then i saw this guy midas rex
remember him from the dc pack you could
only buy for a limited time it's so
limited it's always in the store it
never goes away many of us have noticed
that this version of midas has the
circle with the same crest on it as oro
and aurelia a circle with offshoots of
color like a sunshine pointing downwards
a clear link between all of them but
what we neglected is that midas rex is
actually recognized as a dc character
the dc crossovers are in full force
right now with batman coming here and
the foundation and sloane going the
other way and yet this character
designed for the dc world remains unused
here's where things get interesting the
mark of the sun is actually based on
aton the sun god from ancient egypt hey
another bit of pyramid potential there
always depicted in the same way a
sunshine with the rays only pointing
down towards the earth just like the
chest piece on oro aurelia and midas rex
even his armor has egyptian ruler vibes
and this is where the theory breaks to
pieces what is the purpose of midas rex
why would they design this character to
be the first ever dc fortnite crossover
character and then not use them and
recently we saw an animation which
showed us how midas was recruiting his
cronies and then fortnite deleted that
video
it's a strange time all we know is midas
is important somehow
[Music]
oh this is a good time to bring back a
theory from chapter one the elemental
gods remember this think back to chapter
one and the ice king sitting in his
little bubble this was moments after we
saw a prisoner in his dungeon frozen
away as this guy thawed out it was
revealed he was a fire deity ice vs fire
ended before it started to be honest but
we did get a huge hulking volcano back
to that floaty man at polar peak we
could find a throne room and a meeting
room this table had elements engraved
onto the table with the prisoner's flame
logo by a fallen chair this meant we
know of two gods ice and fire but there
are still others to be revealed
what if these are other gods like the
god of the sun or the queen of reality
or the goddess of thick okay i've gone
too far but you get the idea this
storyline had so much potential in
chapter one yet nothing at all came from
it with the queen in game hitting the
same pose as the ice king and the room
in the among us mode which looks a lot
like the home of the fire god prisoner
maybe just maybe the primordials the
elementals the elders will return
[Music]
theory six is one i've been peddling for
a few weeks now sloane will finally open
the redacted bunker two years we've been
waiting for this two years of not
knowing what the hell is inside that
bunker we've glitched inside we've sat
and watched we've done everything we can
to understand this place suddenly last
season sloane stabbed us in the back
whilst on our mission to stop the last
reality sloane tried to sacrifice us to
prevent the cubes from returning to the
island luckily we didn't perish we
survived i don't know about the bromance
they may not have survived by the time
we reawoke sloane had already moved on
to the next part of her plan to gather
the alien tech and move them across the
island but we don't know actually where
she's been tracked for six weeks now and
she's so close to the bunker it's
unbearable this could be yet another
epic games bait and switch to fool us
all once again but even the mustard we
call donald is shouting about this place
redacted redacted and then redacted
redacted is this too good to be true
will the redacted bunker open its doors
soon hey and check this one out for a
backup idea what if sloane is actually
going to the blue cube it sat there all
season doing nothing and she's
definitely going that way we'll have
answers very soon so click like and
subscribe and something
will the blue cube be our salvation this
season i can't wait to find out so there
we have it six theories which are so
dumb they could come true which do you
think has the most potential i really
want midas rex to have some importance
and i really would like a pyramid thanks
for sticking around to the end and a
special thanks to my discord farm who've
used code adamarro over the last few
weeks link in the description if you
want to join our discord i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]
you